get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel helps make our show possible and
it's an app I actually use myself to
improve my Italian and it's definitely
the first language learning app I'd
recommend to anyone
go check it out so as many of you know
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
has endorsed Bernie Sanders for
president now I've already said and some
of you disagree with me I don't believe
that a o'seas endorsement is going to do
that much for Bernie because her
constituency is more than likely already
supporting Bernie what I mean by that is
if you are someone who is of the mindset
that I don't know who I'm gonna support
but once a OC says who she's supporting
I'm going to support someone it's not
that likely that that's the position
you're in you're probably already
leaning towards or supporting Bernie
Sanders so I know some of you disagree
with that assessment that's fine it's a
difference of opinion it's a beautiful
thing okay something interesting
happened when Bernie Sanders and aoc
were interviewed on the day of their
massive rally I believe that this was
the biggest rally for any candidate in
the twenty twenty election cycle just a
massive massive rally at which a OC
endorsed Bernie I don't know if this was
right before or after the event but a
reporter went to AOC and sort of played
the identity politics games saying why
are you a woman of color endorsing an
old white guy like Bernie Sanders who
was sitting right next to AOC during
this interview and there are many things
that I want to comment on here but first
let's look at the video you made history
with your election and you both are part
of the most diverse Congress in history
this is also the most diverse Democratic
presidential field ever
I'm gonna be a little blunt with you
congresswoman and don't take offense
senator but as a woman of color why back
an old white guy and is this the future
of the party yeah you know I think I'm
actually very excited about this
partnership because it shows what we
have to do in our country is that we
have to come together across race across
gender across generation and across
across class in order to establish our
basic systems as right so a o'seas
answer is is basically fine but we
really need to talk more broadly about
this question because there's some
important stuff here now some people
wrote to me when they saw this video
this question and said David look at
this it's some kind of disgusting
reverse identity politics thing and it's
terrible others wrote to me and said you
know a OC has talked about the
importance of supporting minority
politicians so she could have supported
or endorsed Kamala Harris she could have
endorsed Cory Booker or Tulsi Gabbard or
Andrew yang but she is instead endorsing
Bernie the old white guy and it's a good
thing to bring this up to her and to
give her an opportunity to explain why
she decided to endorse the old white guy
now the reality is that there's multiple
analyses here and I think we should make
all of them in order to really do this
properly in principle there is nothing
wrong with a reporter saying listen
congresswoman you said X is important
how does your endorsement of Bernie
square with that and in this case it's
you've said supporting minority
politicians is important how does
endorsing Bernie square with that no
problem and of course the answer is well
Bernie's platform and Bernie's policies
would get directly to the heart of many
of the inequalities that I want to solve
and a lot of those inequalities run
across racial lines so Bernie's identity
is not at issue here his platform is at
issue and by supporting Bernie I am
supporting minority Americans of all
stripes that would be a completely
reasonable thing to do what I think
people are reacting to is that the
reporter seems to be doing it to sort of
be edgy and controversial or whatever
calling Bernie
an old white guide to his face as part
of the optics of the whole thing and I
get it that it feels sort of
deliberately sensationalist and some
people aren't liking that so I
understand that but there's another
issue here that I have not heard
discussed anywhere which is that Bernie
Sanders is part of a minority group that
is one of the most persecuted minority
groups in human history Bernie Sanders
is Jewish and this is not politically
correct but you know I don't care about
that there are stereotypes and
conspiracies about Jews and money and
power in the United States and
unfortunately it has become almost like
a faux pas on the left to talk about
Jews as a minority group that has
suffered massive historical
discrimination genocide attempted
against Jews kicked out of I don't even
know how many countries it is so there's
another angle to this that is an
important one to discuss if you want to
play the game that the reporter is
playing which is aside from what's
important being the platform of Bernie
not Bernie's identity Bernie's identity
and Bernie's story are of minority
struggle Bernie's parents came to the
United States before the Holocaust they
did the you know outsider immigrant
struggle thing for lack of a better term
but not everybody in Bernie's family
made it to the United States relatives
of Bernie's were killed in
german-occupied Poland during the
Holocaust and Bernie Sanders like many
Jewish Americans was front and center as
a participant in the civil rights
movement of the second half of the 20th
century so you can analyze this by
saying the question was a bad one at
minimum it was a poorly asked question
you can say well a o'seas endorsement is
the correct one because she's focusing
on platform over identity but even if
you don't want to do any of that stuff
and you want to do an identity politics
analysis it shouldn't be a faux pas for
Bernie's identity and Bernie's family
history to be part of the story as it is
for so many Jews who became key players
and partners in the fight for civil
rights of all kinds for all sorts of
people in the United States and
around the world let me know what you
think about this let me know what your
reaction is to the video let me know
what you think about a OCS answer and
handling of it but also let me know what
you think about the other analysis that
exists if we want to suspend at least
for me if I suspend for a moment my
disdain for these types of identity
politics alliances allegiances analyses
call them what they want there's
actually an interesting identity story
that links Bernie Sanders to struggle
for racial equality struggle for class
equality and that's not a story that's
being told and I think it's a story that
is considered as I said a faux pas
unfortunately among many on the left and
also among the white nationalist right
and by the way who sees uses you know
the uber privileged of any of any group
as we've heard many times even from
people I've interviewed on the program I
want to hear from you leave me a reply
on youtube if you're watching this on
youtube or send me a tweet at D Pakman
how do you interpret all of this quick
break right back after this